Justice League is in theaters we're
gonna break down what it means for the
future of DC and humanity what's going
on guys that's right you're here for
Justice League talk today and we've got
a great panel to break it down with
first oh you know he's a friend of the
show he's the writer of Harley Quinn and
poison ivy meet Betty and Veronica
Eisner Award winner
let's welcome mark and Draco Thank You
Helen nice to be here and I call writing
that book with Paul Dini the creator of
Harlequin next oh she's a first-timer
here on screen junkies but she's been
all over the whole channel you've seen
her on the afterbuzz Network and you
know her from Yale TV welcome you Tegel
hi yeah here yeah thanks for being here
for having me heck yes and he is the
co-host of DC movie news Mike Kalinowski
everybody thanks for having me here
let's talk about what this means for the
future of DC here spoilers okay yeah so
Superman came back what does that mean
what are the long-term implications for
Superman being back in the mix now well
I think we saw that him coming back what
he left behind both symbolically and and
metaphorically in this movie is sort of
the darkness that was associated with
him in Man of Steel and Batman versus
Superman it always drove me crazy to
have an actor of immense charm like
Henry Cavill and you let him smile and
we smiles in his movie even with the
lips eg snuff which didn't really bother
me I think people are saying because he
had a moustache and they had the CG but
I I think this is finally the Superman
that we want to see and that Henry
Cavill deserves to play he's he's he's
happy he's celebratory they amped up the
colors in his costume you know there
were a couple of jokes that fell flat
but he just came back from the dead so
he's going to have a couple of clankers
sure his timing might be a little bit
off well yeah what don't we see for
Superman going forward in DC and as part
of the Justice League I really want to
see there be consequences to bringing
him back we kept saying Pet Sematary
like you're gonna bring that up I want
to see that happen I want to see
consequences I think they kind of did a
little bit that the whole fight scene
was us I think as much as we're gonna
get Superman going darker implications
like yeah we at the end as we get the
cavil that everyone wanted us smiling
he's having fun what he does
I think Man of Steel - I think they
should green like that right now get a
great director on that go man of steel -
he's going in Superman right Superman
who do we see as the leader of the
Justice League or they sense gonna be a
roundtable is gonna be alternating do we
think Superman will take them or will
they lean on Wonder Woman it has to be
Wonder Woman was the one with the most
experience she asked how battles are
fought she knows like she even said she
said you know you just talking about
general she's the one with the most
tactical experience Batman's always been
a loner
Superman had was Superman for maybe a
year before he died and these other
three I agree Wonder Woman absolutely is
the leader of this she even said I need
to start leading and stop reacting and
that said I feel like cyborg was the
hero in the end because they would not
have been able to do anything without
him I feel like she's gonna be able to
see the strengths that they all have and
bring them all together also you know
everyone's bickering and she's good at
being like shut up I know what I'm doing
every moment in this movie she had those
moments of being the mother
like when cyborg walks up and she just
smiles at him it she brought out the
best in every character in that movie
yeah yeah what she said - cyborg she
said if I wanted to talk to you a person
I want to talk about I would have got
you when you got the lake and she said
it with a smile where a famine had said
that it would have been threatening the
Steppenwolf mentioned Darkseid
it was teased a little bit - are we
gonna get dark side of course we're
gonna get dark side great of course I
mean absolutely we're gonna get dark
side I think that I think they're doing
the smart thing with that I think
because Thanos and his creation was
actually jim Starlin sort of doing his
riff on Darkseid for Marvel aha so since
Thanos is gonna be the big villain of
the next Avengers movie have billed to
him building that threat being out there
yes and they built that pretty well with
with Stefan Wolfe saying that I need to
prove myself to be able to get back to
apocalypse for him to respect me for him
yeah there were a couple of fun teases
and there are some fun possibilities
laid out before us in the DC Universe
just as far as where the bad guys are
regressing so we talked about Darkseid
but also let's cut to the end credits
yeah a very final scene I really like
that I got you know what I liked Jesse
Eisenberg in that scene better
any Lex Luthor I saw from the earlier
film BVS talked to us about who might be
members of his injustice league well it
really depends them because I think I
think Warner Brothers and the people at
DC are gonna be looking at how this
movie does at the box office and what
there was fans response or one of the
moments in it that really generate noise
with fans because are they gonna bring
people in from the Suicide Squad right
are they gonna bring in the traditional
in Justice Society or in Justice League
or whatever you want to call them to get
assigned supervillains there's all sorts
of different names DC is now doing this
hey our films are gonna be separate
films kind of like an issue of a comic
where you go and you look and you see
flash he's not connected he's not
building to a Justice League number 30
that's gonna be on Stan's next week so I
think this gives the filmmakers a shot
like get flashpoint out there get off
men out there get Shazam out there do
those villains resonate like in when we
get off mean are like if they like Black
Manta or ocean master which one those
can be picking chosen for a final
Justice League to film with the Legion
of Doom so I think it gives the
filmmakers like what villains resonated
in our released films and just
cherry-pick have Lex or Deathstroke go
and pick them and recruit them so it's
it gives them an open door to pick who
they want you talked about watching the
Justice League cartoon and that would be
some fun fanservice for a second great
some of the episodes in that like I just
watch one the other day but I was like
mr. miracle and big Barda it's like
there was the the main cast wasn't even
in it you don't care so if they're good
stories you know you fall in love with
those characters yeah I have no problem
with you recapturing some of the joy of
those Superfriends cartoons Green
Lantern's were teased yeah how do we
think they're going to manifest in this
universe I think they're gonna save that
for when Darkseid shows up I think
that's gonna be the time when Darkseid
is gonna target earth and the Guardians
are going to have to say here are the
Green Lantern and they've got a good
excuse if Darkseid is coming to destroy
earth and colonize earth or terraform
earth or whatever he wants to do the
guardians because we have Hal Jordan Guy
Gardner and Jon Stewart
if apocalypse is the threat that it is
in the comic books they could say we're
giving you three rings for this sector
of space I think we might see all three
of the main DC Universe human champions
three distinct personality who'd be
great as well
we also learned in the movie that
Aquaman has issues with his mom and
Atlantis
how much do you think we're gonna
explore that I'm really excited to see
this Aquaman movie I think it's gonna be
so interesting because it's I love world
building right that's one of the great
things we had about going to the mascara
and seeing you know the amazonian that
is great and I want to see I want to see
this world and I think they're gonna do
beautiful things with it
well the Hall H footage they showed the
the the brief one is do consider well a
lot of it was conceptual art stuff but
it looks like they have created I mean
there were people riding great white
sharks with armor cyborg was just kind
of coming into his own will he learn to
fully control his powers or is that
something that he's going to be kind of
course correcting and feeling his way as
he evolves well I think he's movie I
think we see him gaining more control
over and I'll and I think now that he
and Superman defeated those mother boxes
at the end I think he's got a little bit
more confidence that version of cyborg
was done by Geoff Johns and Jim Lee for
the new 52 the original cyborg first
appeared in the Teen Titans and there
was far there was a lot more flesh on
him and because in this one it's just
like he's a robe it's like a head robot
with a finish yeah no heart but um I
think there'll be a lot of that I think
I'm glad I'm glad they got that out of
the way too because his origin is kind
of do I mean he's this kid who gets
blown to pieces and his father
Frankenstein's up and they had a little
with just enough heaviness an emotion
with the lightness that they can get it
out of the way and now that he's coming
to his own and he smiled at the end when
he did that so he chromatic so yes okay
we got it we got the origin out of the
way Greg Fischer he was just brought so
much to it he was kind of just
underplayed him I think that comes from
his Broadway background ya know I just I
definitely like Christmas I I definitely
think that we're done with him trying to
figure it out I think that's what that
end was was yeah he's got it we're going
norm over Nana and it gave the cyborg
that everyone wanted the kind of cleaner
lines and you got it got his Teen Titans
go tagline
- the audience erupted that sort of
generational because I don't watch that
cartoon right but all the younger people
we already said booyah that's yes you
mentioned the animated series yeah you
mentioned the animated series earlier
and the dynamic of them sitting around
in the control room planning their next
move and like I got I felt like I was
back in as a kid watching
that's animated Sarah you kind of want
we Manor be rebuild but the fact that
they turned into the Hall of Justice and
he comes up like a round table six
chairs and Brandeis like maybe more and
then I didn't notice till the last time
but Alfred just looks at the two of them
and he just kind of smiles if he's right
off on the sides not even focus but it's
just that's what you want to see like
Alfred you know this man's been in a
loan for twenty years and now he has a
family again
it's like it knows that and it's like
stuff like that that maybe the general
Isis won't see it but I did and it's
just that you know it's what I want
after having seen this film multiple
times most of you what are you looking
forward to most going forward what is
what seeds has this planted in your mind
this Justice League film let's start on
the end with Mike and I'll say cuz we
know it's in the pipeline already so for
me I really hope Affleck stays on and we
go forth another Batman film that's what
I'm a Batman guy so that's what I'm
hoping for
but I really want a Superman I want I
don't miss I want Superman I want
Superman I want Brainiac showing up and
it being the two of them and getting a
Cabell that we had in there that's what
I would love to see very cool yeah um I
want to see more of this tone that's all
I'm asking for I think that it's been a
while since we've had you know every up
until this point I feel like everyone's
been either you love it or you hate it
and I think this is the one where people
are going I I like this I had a good
time here here are the problems but here
all the things that worked and I want
that going forward I also would like
more Wonder Woman which luckily looks
like
I think we all agree with you on that
that's unanimous
I'm just excited because I never thought
I'd be interested in seeing a cyborg
standalone movie and I really do I want
to see I would pay good money to see
movies with all of these characters and
standalone movies again and I look
forward to seeing them all reunited
seeing how these relationships grow I
think I'm actually more interested in
the non super heroic stuff with these
characters in the super heroic stuff I
would love them I'd love to see the
equivalent the shwarma scene I just
think I think everyone there are
problems in it but everyone's coming out
it's movie going yeah they did it
they're corrected we want these films
now which I think that was their goal
and they acknowledge that absolutely
what did you think of Justice League
what are you looking forward to going
forward in the DC EU let us know in the
comments section below we want to know I
want to thank this awesome panel for
coming into fun packing this dense
impact of film and giving us some
thoughts mark and Draco yell Tegel Mike
Kalinowski you thank you for being here
and thank you for watching I'm how
Rudnick hit me up on Twitter bye-bye